インスタとかティックトック見てるとなんか可愛い人があまりにを過ぎて若干嫌な
気持ちになります肇社長ですというわけでまた不思議なものを買ってしまいました
こちら
wa
はいこちらですね何か僕それぞもの好きなんですよねまるで本物の鳥のように美しく
飛ぶ
デジタルバードドローンメタファデジタルバードドローン話そんなドローンみたいな声
見た熱で俺のように打つ食らって時でも再現できるのかっていうとすげー気になったん
で買ってみました
ありましたこちらですねうわなんか未来すごいすごいかっこいいメーター5メーター
ふぁい今日は
のコマンダーがもう結婚式してまだスタンダードキットてくれてるって事思いつく
るってことすっとちょっととりあえずあげてみましょう
えこわいよーなった気性能とか何もわかんないんですけどもとりあえず書いてあったの
は
数
ua マンしか作らなきゃいけですなぜか書いてあったことは本当にめちゃくちゃ
美しい鳥のように飛ぶドローンらしいんですよ
今までけど出てないんですよ drawer ドロワーしもういいんぐ食べつしかない
んでそれがまさかにそんな占いで美しく泥が出るなんてもう最もなんか革命的ななにか
なと思ったんで買ってしまいますというドライバーばかめんどくさそう
web 頑張って作ってみます
ああああああ
顔キモカカオでしょうねこれ鳥というよりもなんか
こんちっぽい感じにしますけれどもまだちょっと限界まで型浄化してるんでしょうね
あー
ターン3パターン沿うと
ああ
ua をきたすに多分充電してくれそうですこれでええ
あもう吹なんかやや落としてますけど怖いこういうのやさーいたなぁフィスター作って
いきましょう
なんかそれっぽいパートがあるでちょっとバラッド服っていう風ばっか英語さん入って
英語やばいってうわすげーめちゃくちゃ羽なんですけどやっぱちゃんと飛ぶように計算
されて作られてるからめっちゃ軽量化されてるんでしょうねやばいマジで全部英語で
やばいというのは
主ライトスタッフ
スペインドレックローズスクールぷっ
何を言ってんだ相当やばい英語読めてよかった
読める読めず米語を読める
うぇいが名所んこんな感じだと思いますいいこれまず6月今日
分宮 a 5 ok エアー
イヤーはジェルああああだあフィンガーこれはンって遅いアンダーを
ブーブレ
これうぇっ難しい予定いいえねーなーんにょ完成しましたこんな感じですよ
本当に今までに見たことのないようなドローンですねドローンでも神聞こえねえな感じ
ですね
様子もこれでさあこれでその後にっぽく撮ったらまずすごいですよ
ちょっとちゃんと説明を見ますねおーはーずメーカーふぁい5 b 2 c 2パン
ツァー
not 敗5神戸いいえ
はってよく分かりませんよした分今これ充電中ですね4まだ飛べると思います所でこれ
はこれは同2
まあまあま
大丈夫した上で早速飛ばしてみましょう皆さん忘れてないでしょう
私こう見えても同ローンの操縦勉強を持ってますから
自然の種類ガーン飛ばすのはうまいはずだと思いますだこのタイプのドローンはマジ見
たことないからわかんないですね
今強い
どっ
されません
うぇい号
電源ショットは特殊な aprender あにゃん次ぐメートルワイド端 cad
さあうわーっこれ想像以上に難しい貼っておきますね
p これまさかそのまで滞空するとしててはないか
米望んじゃないなんとなくわかりましたねー
すごいすごいすごいすごいドローンといいがこれ何かあ
ムシですねんかだけどすごい歌ぶん投げたをそれでもこれ
[音楽]
相手上げるトレーニングルームで飛ばしていきましょう室内に飛ばせるのたらこれ
ぐらいだと思ってるんですよね
なんだして飛んでるところまず見てほしいです来るんですよ俺の頭でました
今
[音楽]
re
ています
すげー
全て解けるなんだろう
非常に非常に見苦しいですねこっからかと
できます
ええっなんか俺のイメージだったらもっとそれはわかってるか
駆け巡るイメージだったんですけどおよよ用意
欲しいではん
ああああああこいつ
[音楽]
4 re
car
[音楽]
んでしょ電池不足かな中路どんどん低くなってくる飛ぶ時
10年がブレないのかで間違いなく室内であるもんじゃないですねこれ絶対そこで広い
道路だってこっちが得られてやるだと思いました
ドローンの操縦の免許持ってるとかなんとか言ったんですけども
[音楽]
ブーブーエロ
たっけ w
はい者さんごめんだけまーすフィギュア
訪問者数